en nous mettant à la hauteur des tout-petits
et en regardant ce monde immense à travers leurs petits yeux,
en prenant ces idées d'apparence complexe et en les simplifiant --
pas en jouant aux idiots,
mais en nous focalisant sur le cœur du concept.
Le genre, c'est notre ressenti et notre expression de nous-mêmes.
La sexualité, c'est l'amour, le genre et la famille,
il n'est pas question de sexe.
Ce ne sont que des idées que les enfants peuvent saisir.
Dans un de mes premiers épisodes sur le genre,
j'ai utilisé l'idée de pronoms
pour souligner la définition et introduire des pronoms neutres
comme « iel », « ul » et « ol ».
J'encourage les enfants à réfléchir à leurs propres pronoms
et à demander les leurs à leurs amis.
Dans les épisodes suivants, je me repose sur cette fondation
et introduis des mots savants comme « non binaire » et « transgenre ».
Je reçois des mails de spectateurs de 20 ans
qui utilisent mes vidéos
pour expliquer les genres non binaires à leurs grands-parents.
Mais je reçois un commentaire à répétition :
« Laissez les enfants être des enfants. »
Cela part d'un bon sentiment,
mais seulement si cela inclut tous les enfants.
Il y a quelques semaines,
un jeune de 15 ans à Huntsville, en Alabama,
s'est suicidé après avoir été maltraité car il été gay.
En 2018, c'était un enfant de sept ans
à Denver, dans le Colorado.
Il y en a eu et il y en aura beaucoup d'autres.
Les adolescents lesbiens, gays et bisexuels
ont trois fois plus de risques de faire une tentative de suicide
que leurs pairs hétérosexuels
et pour les adolescents transgenres, les risques sont six fois plus élevés.
D'après une étude, environ un tiers des jeunes sans-abri
s'identifient comme lesbiens, gays, bisexuels ou en questionnement
et environ 4% des jeunes sans-abri
s'identifient comme étant transgenres,
comparé à 1% dans la population en général.
D'après Human Rights Campaign,
il y a eu 128 meurtres de personnes transgenres
dans 87 villes à travers 32 États
depuis 2013.
Et ce ne sont que les cas signalés.
Et 80% de ces victimes étaient des femmes transgenres de couleur.
La situation des queers est sombre,
c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire.
Les commentaires YouTube sous mes vidéos
ne sont pas beaucoup mieux.
Je suis habituée au harcèlement,
je reçois au quotidien des messages disant que je suis une pédophile
et que je devrais me suicider de façons multiples et créatives.
J'ai dû bloquer le mot « camion »
car quelqu'un voulait que je sois écrasée par un camion.
« Douche » et « four » y sont également,
pour la référence moins créative et plus dérangeante à l'holocauste.
Quand les néo-nazis ont manifesté à Charlottesville,
je n'ai pas été surprise d'apprendre
que le créateur d'un mème violent sur Reddit au sujet d'un de mes épisodes
était dans la foule avec les torches.
Ce barrage de négativité est ce à quoi nous sommes confrontés :
les statistiques accablantes, la violence, les risques pour la santé mentale,
la réponse bien intentionnée mais bancale que mes parents m'ont donnée
lors de mon coming out :
ils ne voulaient pas que j'aie une vie plus difficile.
C'est à cela que nous sommes confrontés.
Mais face à tout cela,
je choisis la joie.
Je choisis les arcs-en-ciel, les licornes et les paillettes
et je chante que l'on peut être gay avec mon ours en peluche d'enfance.
Je crée des contenus queers pour les enfants
car à leur âge, j'aurais aimé en avoir.
Je crée cela pour que les autres ne traversent pas ce que j'ai traversé :
ne pas comprendre mon identité
car je n'étais pas exposée à la personne que je pouvais être.
J'enseigne et je partage ce message à travers de la joie et de la positivité
plutôt que de le formuler autour des difficultés de la vie queer.
Je veux que les enfants deviennent eux-mêmes
avec de la fierté pour qui ils sont et qui ils peuvent être,
peu importe qui ils aiment,
ce qu'ils portent ou les pronoms qu'ils utilisent.
Je veux qu'ils aiment les autres pour leurs différences,
pas malgré elles.
Je pense qu'encourager cette fierté et cette empathie
fera du monde un lieu plus bienveillant et égalitaire
et luttera contre l'intolérance et la haine couvant dans notre monde.
Parlez de genre à un enfant.
Parlez de sexualité à un enfant.
Enseignez-leur le consentement.
Dites-leur que les garçons peuvent porter des robes
et les filles peuvent s'exprimer.
Répandons une joie queer radicale.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)